ungewöhnlich hoher Besuch in der
Feuerwehrwache Neukölln die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin von Berlin im Wahlkampf
und die bundesinnenministerin zeigen
sich an der Seite der Einsatzkräfte der
Schock über die Silvesternacht sitzt
noch immer tief
so ein Silvester darf es nicht noch
einmal geben
bestandene Einsatzleiter die seit vielen
Jahrzehnten im Dienst sind die haben das
erste mal Angst gehabt
15 Einsatzkräfte werden verletzt als
überwiegend junge Männer sie mit
Feuerwerkskörpern und
Schreckschusspistolen attackieren die
bundesinnenministerin spricht schnell
von harten Strafen für widerliche Taten
und über die Herkunft der Täter es waren
überwiegend Täter mit
Migrationshintergrund das muss man auch
ansprechen man muss auf der anderen
Seite aber auch ansprechen dass das
natürlich für die Bevölkerung in den
Brennpunkten gerade auch diejenigen
trefft die Migrationshintergrund haben
die sind auch gleichermaßen Opfer in
Deutschland hat fast jeder dritte einen
Migrationshintergrund in Köln jeder
zweite was also folgt aus der Erkenntnis
dass unter den Festgenommenen fast 20
Nationen vertreten sind das zwei Drittel
von ihnen keinen deutschen Pass haben
im Netz tobt es abriegeln
zusammentreiben scharf zurückschießen
zeigen wer der Boss ist
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann von
der FDP will diejenigen ohne
Aufenthaltsrecht ausweisen und
abschieben und die Berliner CDU auch sie
im Wahlkampf für die Namen der 45
deutschen Verdächtigen erfahren weil sie
dort nicht erwartet was sie unter
Deutsch versteht diese Aufteilung und
Bürgerinnen und Bürger erster und
zweiter Klasse die geht in eine völlig
falsche Richtung das geht überhaupt
nicht und das sendet das falsche Signal
nämlich es ist egal was ihr macht ihr
werdet nie dazugehören
Bezirksstadtrat Falko Lieke in seinem
Kiez seit einem Vierteljahrhundert macht
der CDU Mann Politik in Neukölln
beobachtet die Bildung von
Parallelgesellschaften der Staat muss
zeigen er ist hier Chef auf der Straße
und nicht irgendwelche wild gewordenen
Chaoten auf der einen Seite auf der
anderen Seite aber auch in den Schulen
mit Polizeibeamten unterwegs zu sein und
mit den Kindern und Jugendlichen zu
sprechen und zu zeigen Polizei ist nicht
euer feind wir die Gesellschaft der
Staat ist nicht euer feind warum manche
Jugendliche den Staat als Feind
betrachten sich benehmen als gehörten
sie nicht dazu das erklären Songül
chatin Kaya und ihr Kollege im
Neuköllner Jugendclub jo 22 auch so weil
ihnen genau das vermittelt werde
teilweise ist es einfach ihr Alltag dass
sie Rassismus Erfahrungen sammeln dass
sie abgelehnt werden dass sie immer
wieder weggedrängt werden
wir sammeln auch Rassismus Erfahrungen
ständig ja obwohl wir hier geboren sind
und hier studiert haben und obwohl man
jetzt vom Akzent her nicht irgendwie
sagen könnte ob ich jetzt Deutsche bin
oder ob ich jetzt Türkin bin
im Laufe der Woche und der Debatte wird
klar die Gründe für den Silvester
Krawall sind vielfältig Täter sind
vermutlich junge Männer in schwierigen
sozialen Lagen nach fast drei Jahren
Pandemie aus Familien mit wenig Bildung
und einem anderen kulturellen Umfeld sie
sind häufig Ziel von Rassismus und
anfällig für Gruppendynamiken
insgesamt ist die Zahlen junger
migrantischer Straftäter im Vergleich zu
ihren deutschen Alters- und
Geschlechtsgenossen leicht erhöht so
dass Institut für kriminalwissenschaften
in Münster für geflüchtete aus
Kriegsgebieten käme noch hinzu dass die
Gewalt erfahren haben in ihren
Herkunftsländern auf der Flucht was dann
ein Stück weit gewaltrisiken auch noch
beeinflussen kann das sind
hintergrundfaktoren die das ein bisschen
mit erklären können generell muss aber
sagen natürlich auch bei jungen Menschen
mit migrationsbezügen ist gewaltsames
Verhalten die Ausnahme Jugend
Kriminalität ist in Deutschland
insgesamt rückläufig und die 40.000
Angriffe auf Polizeibeamte im Jahr 2021
wurden zu 70% von deutschen
am Ende wenn wir alle Analysen haben und
wenn auch die Gerichte entscheiden
werden wir sehen die vielen anderen
Faktoren spielen eine Rolle nur eben
stereotyp und vorurteilsvoll und
vorschnell über Gruppen zu reden und
dann zu suggerieren jetzt ließe sich
schnell Sicherheit herstellen das ist
gefährlich und hilft auch der Politik
nicht weil dann wird werden
populistische und extremistische und
radikale Kräfte nach noch viel härteren
Strafen rufen bereits 2017 wurde das
Strafgesetz verschärft für tägliche
Angriffe auf Einsatzkräfte stehen nun
bis zu fünf Jahre Gefängnis verhindert
hat das den Silvester Krawall nicht
und bei mir ist jetzt der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der CDU
im Bundestag Torsten frei schönen guten
Abend guten Abend Frau bernerty Herr
frei wir haben jetzt einige sehr
nachdenkliche Stimmen gehört die ist
nicht für sinnvoll halten nach der
Herkunft vermeintlicher Täter zu fragen
in dieser Debatte sie gehören zu
denjenigen die relativ früh in der
Debatte festgestellt haben es gebe ein
erschreckendes Problem mit rohen
gewaltbereiten
integrationsverweigern das haben sie in
der Rheinischen Post gesagt warum ist
das aus ihrer Sicht der richtige Ansatz
um über das Problem zu sprechen es gibt
sicherlich nicht den einen Grund und mit
Sicherheit ist es nicht ein
Migrationshintergrund der dafür sorgt
dass man gewalttätig wird aber wenn man
sich die Zahlen hier in Berlin in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und anderen Orts
anschaut dann kann man schon sehen dass
es hier eine Häufung gibt und ich finde
in der jetzigen Situation kommt darauf
an dass man vorurteilsfrei sich mit den
Fakten beschäftigt weil nur das wird die
Möglichkeit eröffnen dass man auch
wirklich Lösungswege erkennen und
erarbeiten kann wenn sie die die Zahlen
und die Fakten ansprechen muss ich ganz
neue Zahlen reinbringen die gerade eben
gekommen sind der Tagesspiegel berichtet
dass die Polizei hier in Berlin noch mal
korrigiert und präzisiert von den
Festgenommenen sind nur 38 festgenommene
wegen Böller Angriffen jetzt in Verdacht
und die Mehrheit davon ist deutsch
ändert das ihre Analyse nein das ändert
die Analyse nicht weil wir es mit einem
grundlegenden Problem zu tun haben
zunächst einmal ist es ja nicht
maßgeblich ob es jetzt Böller Angriffe
waren oder andere tägliche Angriffe auf
Polizisten oder Rettungskräfte und wir
haben auch in den Vorjahren ähnliche
Erlebnisse gehabt nicht nur die Kölner
Silvesternacht auch der Opernplatz in
Frankfurt oder der Schlossgarten in
Stuttgart im Sommer 2020 all das zeigt
letztlich dass wir ein großes Problem
mit Gewalt gegen polizei und
Rettungskräfte haben und da geht's jetzt
rum klar zu analysieren was könnten die
Ursachen sein und was sind die Wege raus
aus dieser Situation jetzt haben sie
gerade bei der Problembeschreibung das
Thema Integration und
Migrationshintergrund weggelassen das
ist aber in ihrer Partei in den letzten
Tagen nicht vorwiegend der Fall gewesen
warum wartet man nicht wir haben jetzt
gesehen die täglich kommen Nachrichten
von ähnlichen Ausbrüchen in ganz
Deutschland zum Beispiel in Sachsen
vergleichbare Gewalt gegen ordnungs- und
Rettungskräfte von urdeutschen
Tatverdächtigen ausgeführt warum also
diese Konzentration auf den Hintergrund
und auf die Herkunft das ist ein
ursachenpfad es ist nicht der einzige
ich will das mal ganz deutlich sagen
Angriffe tägliche Angriffe auf
Polizisten auf Rettungskräfte das was
wir hier erlebt haben wo Familien in
dieser Silvesternacht friedlich gefeiert
haben und damit in Gefahr gekommen sind
das ist etwas was der Rechtsstaat nicht
akzeptieren kann und wir werden deshalb
jeden klar attackieren müssen der
Verachtung gegenüber unserer
Gesellschaft und dem Rechtsstaat zeigt
unabhängig seiner Herkunft der Berliner
CDU ist das Thema so wichtig dass Sie
noch einmal gesondert nach den Vornamen
der Tatverdächtigen mit deutschen Pass
gefragt hat wie sinnvoll ist das denn
wenn sie sagen es ist nur all die
Herkunft ist nur eine von vielen Fragen
die man klären muss also Straftaten sind
Straftaten unabhängig davon ob sie von
einem deutschen oder einem Ausländer
oder einem Menschen mit hinter
Migrationshintergrund begangen werden
aber in der jetzigen wenn sie aber mal
schauen was ist passiert in den Tagen
nach Silvester wir haben über ein
böllerverbot in Deutschland diskutiert
und wir sehen doch jetzt mit einigen
Tagen Abstand dass das eine Debatte ist
die völlig auf ein Nebengleis führt wir
haben hier ein ganz grundsätzliches
Problem mit Gewalt gegen staatliche
Organe gegen Menschen das sind auch
Menschen um die es hier geht und deshalb
ist es glaube ich schon sehr bedeutsam
dass man vorurteilsfrei sich mit den
Fakten beschäftigt und da gehört das mit
dazu das haben wir auch mögliche
Gegenmittel die Innenministerin redet
jetzt über eine Beschaffung des
Waffenrechtes unterstützt die Union das
also wir werden es uns genau anschauen
müssen die Regierung hat eine
Novellierung des Waffengesetzes
angekündigt wir unterstützen alles was
zu mehr Sicherheit führt auf der anderen
Seite muss man sagen dass wir heute
schon eines der schärfsten Waffengesetze
weltweit haben und wenn ich mir den
jüngsten Vorschlag der
bundesinnenministerin anschaue nämlich
Schreckschusspistolen auch im Erwerb an
den kleinen Waffenschein zu knüpfen da
muss man sagen den kleinen Waffenschein
braucht man schon beim Führen von
schreckstoß Waffen und darüber hinaus
ist auch das Schießen umfassen
sanktioniert da kommt es auch eher
darauf an das geltendes Recht wirklich
schnell und konsequent umgesetzt wird
sie selber fordern eine Debatte im
Bundestag in der ersten Sitzungswoche da
werden wir dann die Argumente und die
Argumente der Gegenseite hören erstmal
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch sehr
gerne